What we eat is clearly not just based on biological influence, but culture
plays a factor as well. The psychology of what we eat has to do with external
factors, such as the sight of food, the smell of food, and importantly, the
culture in which we were raised. That is, when one person may find delicious,
another person may find inedible. Children, for example, who are exposed to
spicy foods early in life quickly develop a taste and even cravings for the
spicy foods later in life. Likewise, people who were not exposed to spicy foods
find them too overpowering for them. Similarly, brains and intestines are
delicious in some cultures. Yet beef is disgusting, or even sacrilegious in
others. In most cases, except for sweets, food preferences are acquired, and
learned tastes. It's safe to say that food and cuisine are key traits of any
culture, with each culture having it's own unique cuisine and food.